to just finish the tournament on a high
because there's nothing worse than
losing your final round match and we've
seen dudas struggle so he will come up
he will try to level up and play the big
boss you know this is what he's here for
to challenge his the closest tour rival
and they're off and we see that the game
has opened with the g-pawn moving one
square forward yep won B3 we saw
yesterday from Magnus and now it's one
G3 but he's as strange it's not quite as
strange he has transposed the position
now into an English opening and it's
what we call the symmetrical English
because look at the pawn structure look
at the pieces it's completely
symmetrical do dirt playing copycat and
this has quite a good reputation for
black this exact position black is very
flexible you can push a bunch of
different pawns here Black's Knight can
come out what we'll do to choose he
pushes this Pawn now white usually hear
either castles or pushes the white Pawn
in the center a couple of squares this
is an alternative as well Magnus he
mentioned that word attack in his
interview with Tanya and he's going for
the attack it's only move six and he's
pushed the H1 forward trying to continue
pushing and if he does get the
opportunity to push Harry the H1 Square
further forward black will seriously
have some issues to deal with and uh in
looking at the database I can see that
this was a specialty of Magnus in 2019
he used it to draw with the white pieces
against rustam kazimov and also Wesley
so so uh for some reason it's kind of
fallen out of a favor with Magnus but
it's back it's also been popular with
Anish giri he's also played it twice
Wang Hao Michael Adams I've made this so
this is a very established move
yeah I think I faced it myself before in
some Blitz Games in some rapid games and
it is surprisingly scary white is
keeping his King in the center and white
often keeps the king in the middle for a
lot longer essentially he's saying to
Black I'm going to keep pushing the H
porn you can not really Castle safely on
this King side anymore on the left side
of the board on the right side sorry
uh just because you're going to come
under Fire there and Duda
as black you're kind of committed to a
plan Black's last pawn move pushing the
pawn to E6 has created a square for his
Knight but
um I don't think you can play automatic
moves anymore this is very much what
Duda likes to do actually against me
once he pushed the H Pawn forward on
move three he likes to kind of start
attacking he doesn't want to be on the
back foot reacting there's some Theory
here as well I remember some games with
some Indian youngsters sadwani won a
very instructive game here a while ago
yeah and I can tell you that there are
two very popular moves the most popular
move by far is actually to lift Black's
H porn one square forward getting ready
to meet White's Pawn Advance with a
block and another alternative is
actually just to develop the Knight but
that isn't as popular the another less
popular one is actually to pick up the
edge pawn and block the H4 Pawn
immediately
so either way we're expecting Duda to at
least prepare to react to White's h-born
push
um either way it's early days in Magnus
he's got the music going yeah he's in
his comfort zone he's at the well on top
of the world right now he must be
feeling so high so happy with his
performance and confident as well these
two players have played each other 36
times in Rapid chess over the past two
seasons of The meltwater Champions chess
Tour 18 wins for Magnus against Judo you
said it many times Ivanka
Agnes has been very dominant against
Duda and I guess this is proof yeah but
I mean that's kind of traditionally been
the soundtrack you know it's always been
like Magnus playing fantastic chess you
know he's almost been able to play
anything against Duda and managed to win
but these last two matches that they've
played in the crypto Cup and the aim
chess it's been Duda who's actually won
so sure not so easy yeah and it's often
in the biggest clashes in the finals or
uh for example in the World Cup
semi-final do the Triumph there in the
rapid tie breaks
um due to ended magnus's long long
unbeaten run in the last major Duda one
so it's often the big matches where Duda
saves his best
it's normally in the prelim stage where
Magnus just kind of rolls over Duda it's
often when Duda has nothing left to play
for that's when bad things happen so it
just depends on duda's motivation if
he's really focused if he's determined
to
beat Magnus yet again then I think he's
capable we have seen something from Duda
which is he has a tendency to tilt and
when things go really wrong they can go
catastrophically wrong and I do remember
in the Oslo Esports where Magnus just
opened with this really bizarre oh yeah
one F3 yeah and it was wasn't serious
but it really put off Duda and he just
couldn't recover and Magnus won in three
games psychological victory for Magnus
in that match yeah that's one area that
Duda needs to put serious work in uh he
got to the candidates of course he won
the World Cup but I think in order to
break into the top five top ten in the
world consistently dudo needs to just be
a bit more
stable and keep those emotions in check
and meanwhile there have been a few
moves on the board both sides are
castled so white has gone away from the
plan of pushing the H porn up but he has
forced a breakthrough in the center and
if we jump in Ivanka I'm curious this
position is brand new to me uh has it
been played before nope
answer I mean this bishop
mortally unusual never been played it's
been much more common to actually
capture the Knight on C6 or capture a
pawn in the middle of the board but
having said that the players were
already in a variation which had only
been played four times so it wasn't like
they were in mainstream Waters yeah and
this last move by Magnus it's very very
provocative he's asking Duda for example
to jump forward with his Knight to try
and attack this bishop I'm assuming here
well you can't let this bishop be
captured you'll lose the bishop pair and
your Pawn structure will be damaged so
I'm assuming Magnus wants to move his
Bishop yet again attacking the black
queen and finally we do see a purpose
for this odd looking porn move on H4 it
looks like the pawn is just doing
nothing there but it does protect the
bishop white gains time against the
queen and black center might fall apart
next move so uh that's one idea that
might not quite work for doodle right
now and you can't really release the
central tension if you take this Pawn
then after Knight takes Knight suddenly
black has some very weak pawns and these
will fall off over the next few moves
for example White's Bishop can already
start getting Rudy and uh okay dude
deciding not to release the tension he's
just waiting he shuffles his Rook across
he's asking Magnus to take in the center
now because after a trade of Pawns
Black's Rook comes to life and this is a
very thematic exchange sacrifice as we
call it uh for example if white ignores
the threat of Rook takes Bishop then I
think this is automatic for Duda you
capture a bishop yes you've given up a
rook in return but white structure is
eternally damaged and uh huge weaknesses
especially on the dark squares for
example the bishop can already come to
Target this pawn and this type of idea
I've seen in many games I first saw it
in a game by Gary kasparo for many many
many years ago
and uh I think this is what Duda is
aiming for but Magnus he won't be so
compliant he won't allow this to happen
yeah if Magnus allows this to happen
I would be very shocked I bet my house
sees so he's not going to let this
happen so Magnus maybe he'll take on
this square but he definitely wouldn't
allow this second capture of the uh of
the dark Square Bishop that holds
White's position together
yeah critical moment in the game I do
like uh Doodles Rook move even though
the bar doesn't necessarily like it I
like the fact that it's it's a very
flexible move and black is signaling to
push those pawns but at the same time
hasn't committed to doing anything
concrete just yet and is now apt to
Magnus you know all the choices in his
hands you know captain of the night
capture the pawn as you indicated or is
he going to develop or something yeah
for example he could keep the tension
just Shuffle his Rook across but the
calculation is starting to happen it's
getting very Concrete in this brand new
position already both players on their
own it's only move 11. you do like that
remember it's a match with four rapid
games the winner in the rapid portion
takes seven hundred seven thousand five
hundred dollars and three points if it
goes to tie breaks then the winner gets
five thousand dollars on the loser two
thousand five hundred dollars
and do you think what do you think is
the most likely in this one will mine is
just keep on being dominant like over
the last few days so I could go to tie
breaks for example yeah that's the thing
because if we just look at this
tournament alone it's pretty
straightforward to say Magnus is in
charge Magnus is on a roll Magnus is
focused but I think Ivanka and I we've
both seen so many examples throughout
chess history of players achieving their
goals and then taking the foot off the
pedal and not being able to kind of play
at their best anymore it happened to me
when I got my Grandmaster title I still
had a couple of games left in that
tournament and I just couldn't I
couldn't get my head back in the game
and I've won a few tournaments with a
round to spare two rounds to spare and
it's so hard to focus so anything could
still happen it dude is the type of
player as well where yes he can go on
really bad runs but if you just give him
one chance then his confidence perks
right up and he he's a very streaky
player if he starts winning he might not
stop so the first game or two I think
will be essential to decide so it is a
mental game very much for Magnus Carlsen
today as well he is thinking now on his
next move and we couldn't finish off the
season without saying hello to someone
who has been a regular in this studio
throughout the whole season Grandmaster
Simon Williams Ginger DM hi it's so nice
to see you Simon
hi there yeah it's good to uh good to
pop in I'm a little bit late this time
on arriving
um but yeah yeah it's really cool to see
you all and say hello I'm I'm afraid I'm
in a little bit of a dark room at the
moment but uh I'm here in spirit anyway
so are you all doing okay we are it's
been it's been a fun week of Chess right
yeah but we have missed you Simon very
much
have you been following the tour finals
what have you thought of it Simon
is there a tournament going on all right
yeah no I I have a bit and um just just
Magnus has been incredible right
um playing playing Amazing chess and I
love their view that they've got over
the over the bridge and everything it
looks it looks fantastic the whole event
so uh quite jealous of everyone there I
agree I agree and looking back at the
whole season there's been nine
tournaments a bunch of these we've seen
a bunch of different players young ones
older ones women men what has been a
highlight for you what will you remember
from the 2022 season
I am well I think personally uh being in
the studio with you lovely people and
everyone behind the scene and um you
know I don't know if everyone watching
this stream understands like just how
many brilliant people there are over in
Norway who make it so much fun the
broadcast
um and obviously the chess I mean the
chess has been great right it's been
really exciting the format's been uh top
level and just the players we've had
some of the games uh that have been
played have been like riveting to uh to
watch and uh and also a couple of nights
out to remember as well so uh yes so
it's been good all-round for me uh for a
personal point of view and from the
chess point of view yeah you made it a
fantastic debut in the studio Simon and
we had so much fun with you in the
studio you've been at the good night
reporting this season and you've had
many good comments and we have something
we want to show you and we have to shift
the camera to David for it to be
possible for us oh no
worried
[Laughter]
David please you don't need strip too
much
oh my words what is happening here oh
there we go Simon Just For You
I love it just resign your catchphrase
that is I like the T-shirt that's really
cool that's really good yeah I'm glad
you are wearing a t-shirt David I was
getting a little bit worried there for a
moment so you know
maybe I'm not sure
definitely
awesome t-shirt pretty cool we're gonna
make sure to send you one Simon that has
been one of many of your catchphrases
this season just resign but do you think
it's been mostly entertaining what the
player has been up to
be brilliant I mean uh like like say
we've had so many all the top players
playing and fighting
I've Loved about this season is uh there
hasn't been any like really quick draws
right there's been fighting chess from
start to finish
um we've had some really wacky openings
I mean Magnus went a bit mental didn't
he at one stage or some of the weird
stuff he was playing so uh all in all
it's just been great yeah really really
good fun to watch and I hope everyone
else watching has been enjoying it just
as much as uh I have commentating with
you guys in the studio
it's really been a fun year and talking
of the T-shirt just resign we of course
want to give a t-shirt to the viewers as
well so we're gonna have a quiz of today
where the t-shirt is the price and of
course we have to challenge Simon and
the quiz of today as well tough one
we're putting you on the spot side not
again
2021 season when we did this to you
every day yeah every day it was a new
surprise
and here he goes so we're asking our
viewers at home and maybe you also Simon
can have a go to caption this picture
and there we have Ramesh and we have
Paul Prague fast asleep watching the
basketball game oh wow it looks a bit
past his bedtime doesn't it really I
mean it's like and what's that guy doing
in the background you know so that's the
other thing so
um I don't know I think Ramesh is just
saying like he he's the king here's my
kid he can get some sleep occasionally
because he's the boss he's a future
world champion let him sleep you know so
uh something along those lines but what
is the guy doing in the background he's
like getting in there as well so yeah so
impressive little photo there yeah so
where was that that was that uh um
somewhere in San Francisco right yep the
four players in San Francisco went to a
basketball game next versus Warriors and
we know Magnus really enjoyed it Denise
really enjoyed it but prag well it had
been a long day of chess
I think he's like thinking I just want
to stick to the chest right I don't you
know this this basketball is not for me
by the looks of that so uh yeah yeah
all right Simon we are finishing off uh
the season today following game one here
between Magnus Carlsen and young
Christoph Duda I'm not sure if you can
see the board but if you can I do see
that Harry has been pushed in this game
already what do you think of the
position
um looks looks pretty even at the moment
I I figure I I mean obviously I like
this H Pawn the wing Pawn being pushed
very early one of the things I love
doing uh all the time uh Black's got a
worse Pawn structure uh but they've also
got potential those Pawns in the middle
so I think it's still quite early days
um and I would say you know fairly
fairly equal at this moment in time but
I'm sure I'm sure things will heat up
quickly right so especially if that
Harry porn could just get pushing push
him push diary
fantastic time and it was so good to see
you again we wish you uh happy holidays
when that time comes and I hope to see
you again in the 2023 season
cheers everyone you have a great uh
great day so okay great night even lucky
you Simon enjoy enjoy
oh so nice to see Simon Williams again
Ginger GM he's been a regular in the
studio and we hope to see him back in
the 2023 season
you said this could get interesting
didn't really like the black pool
structure so what is happening in this
game yeah I have to completely agree
with Simon it's in the balance but it is
about to heat up the pawn structure is
very imbalanced uh here we do see black
with almost what we call hanging Pawns
in the center black C and D pawns they
protect each other yes but they're on
open files they are targets potentially
for the white Rooks and black does have
an isolated report the a pawn doodle was
trying to push that as far down the
board as possible
unclear exactly what the purpose was
Magnus has blocked that pawn now the
black apron and he's saying okay what's
your plan next
and I guess that's the Dilemma for dudo
right now how does he improve the black
pieces they already look pretty well
placed it's hard to imagine other than
the black queen perhaps how to improve
any of them and he is at a loss for a
plan he simply pushes his H Pawn this
time to block and Magnus does take the
opportunity to centralize yeah I have to
say I agree with you there David it
looks very unclear for Duda I have to
admit I I'm a bit baffled by a magnus's
sophisticated play I had something much
more direct in mind I thought that
Magnus was gonna perhaps just explode
open the center or just put their Rooks
on the open line and instead he's put
his work on a rather mysterious line I
mean it's just blocked it's looking at
its Queen and Bishop what does Magnus
have in store is he planning to sidestep
with the queen and go for the week a
pawn yeah that could be one potential
idea here for Magnus and Duda also down
significantly on the clock I think
Magnus is just putting his pieces on
good squares and saying okay it's up to
you to create something like you said
this this could be one idea if black is
too slow White's Queen sidestepping
and this is a severe weakness
I guess as well you'll write Ivanka this
is an annoying pin so you can't push the
white E Pawn anytime soon
but if you do move your queen out the
way then there might be ideas I just
don't see what black is doing for
example if black just makes a waiting
move one idea that I love for white in
these types of positions I'm not sure
it's going to happen yet but it might
happen later is to actually plant a
bishop on this square and it looks a bit
counterintuitive it looks
anti-positional because after a trade of
Bishops white has double pawns however
white has also the perfect hiding place
for a king right now the white King on
this Square on G2 is going to be safe
forever and then you can focus your
attentions on the center I think Magnus
is just saying now for example you can
never push pawns as black because the
after a trade here the D Pawn is always
going to be weak so I think it's just
lining up he's just preparing for any
pawn breaks for black you can now win
the pawn on D5 so yeah it's this is
almost a waiting game here but on the
clocks that is not favoring Duda right
now he's a very active player okay he
doesn't move his Queen he moves his King
instead so do that very very active
player he's going to be feeling
uncomfortable he wants to do something
Dynamic he wants to attack he wants to
create threats but he's reduced to just
waiting moves I guess the only idea
behind this king move is to plant his
Bishop to attack the White Queen but is
this really going to be that effective
seems unlikely white can always just
move the queen out the way
harassing the queen and David you called
it it's like you are channeling your
inner Magnus yeah
yeah I mean this Pawn structure Ivanka
if the bishops get traded I don't think
Duda should capture right now but this
Pawn structure it comes from the karakan
defense where black has doubled f-pawns
I've played some games in the ready as
white where you get these Pawns in Blitz
Games this is just a winning position
for white essentially because you put
your King on this square and the rest of
the board you can worry about later you
just have a safe King four Pawns in
front to protect
um I also call this the bug house
structure because in a variant of Chess
Bug House chess um yeah you'll never
ever get checkmated with pawns like this
meanwhile Duda doesn't get tempted to
capture he does indeed start harassing
the White Queen he hits her and uh after
the queen stepped forward it looks like
she's trapped but Magnus found a nice
way to counter-attack he traded off a
set of pieces now and he offers the
queen trade I'm surprised that this last
couple of moves I must admit I thought
Magnus had something more aggressive in
mind but he's hoping that after the
Queens come off the board that black has
a weak Pawn Yeah and it is a weak pawn
and there's no way to defend that pawn
in fact perhaps you could jump in with
the black Bishop just defend but uh yeah
it does feel as if white now would have
the opportunity maybe to blow open the
center of the board like does have the
Bishops which makes me favor Black the
computer loves Bishops that's why the
evaluation bar has gone up in Black's
favor and these two pieces control a lot
of squares they control most of the
squares that the white Rooks want to use
actually
um so perhaps things turning into favor
it does look like Magnus just rushed a
bit I was praising his play but suddenly
two three moves later the wrong
exchanges perhaps and it looks like
black could be the one with the
advantage it's still not going to be
easy for Duda to convert this but he
needs to perhaps even just give up this
pawn and Go Active with his pieces yeah
there are also targets for the black
Brooks later on remember
so yeah maybe you can start going for
them now yeah I have to admit you kind
of took the words right out of my mouth
I was going to point that out yes the
black porn is weak but so is why it's B2
born and I do like the potential of
black staff Square Bishop it's so good
this guy can reroute itself as well to
the long diagonal and soften up the
White Queen side yeah
really surprised I must say I thought
Duda was just about to come under
pressure
Magnus perhaps because he's won the
tournament just not really bothering to
dive into a long deep think and uh okay
slightly shaking his head there for
world number one maybe realizing that he
had more promising Alternatives earlier
maybe in a little bit of trouble here in
the first game Magnus Carlsen but he has
a lot of time on the clock right now
it's Duda thinking we just had Ginger GM
on the show he finished off with a
little bit of a toast with his uh wine
or beer and if Simon got a beer for
every time this season he has a bet on
the right move he would constantly be
very tipsy
I think you'll find it I mean that yeah
maybe Simon what are we betting for
about this I think the first drink
tomorrow okay
very nice yeah Will Yan find this
important porn push
are you a drink Simon
I only drink champagne my friend oh yeah
okay I'll tell you what whatever the
first choice is okay I bet you that
Magnus you can choose if Magnus finds it
or not to get your point back okay what
is the first move okay the choice oh wow
this is difficult this is almost
impossible what's best I don't think
you'll find this oh do you wanna have a
pet then another drink another drink
okay okay good man
what
[Music]
[Laughter]
he has won a lot of bets against you
David yeah that was a very expensive
night for me in Oslo buying slime and
drinks but he's uh yeah he's just great
at the prediction game master you yeah
the blunders correct
and uh well talking about the prediction
game David kind of called it he said
black would be targeting the bee pawn
and that's the move that has happened
and Magnus just realizing that he needs
to accelerate the play has uh broken the
black stronghold in the center yeah so
we've seen a trade of Pawns in the
center we might see a trade of the light
squared Bishops but it's all about
whether black can take advantage now
Black's Rook can capture on B2 anytime
he wants black's Bishop also has lots of
targets look at all the white pawns that
are on dark squares what does black have
darts go a bishop so to me despite the
evaluation bar being in the middle it
does feel like black is the only one who
can play for Advantage but maybe just
with his last couple of moves uh it's
too late maybe just all the pieces are
flying off the board it does look like
Magnus has found a way to liquify
liquidate the position
and force the draw oh will we see a draw
in this game one
it is thinking now we're gonna go to San
Francisco it is the final day of the
tour finals with four players and Tanya
on-site in San Francisco how are you
guys doing on this final day Tanya
we're having so much fun here Kaya and
even though we do have a winner of the
tournament I have to say the matchups
today I just love them some really epic
fights here Magnus is facing his Nemesis
Duda we've got an all Indian clash with
Prague against Argenta big day of Chess
and to enjoy all of that we do have a
young chess fan here with us it is Seb
he is a local talent here from the Bay
Area Sam welcome to the show are you
enjoying yourselves yes I'm enjoying uh
being here very much it's a great
experience to see the players in action
and
meet them I have to ask you when did you
start playing chess uh I started playing
chess when I was five years old but I
didn't really play all I did was know
how to move the pieces and I actually
basically started playing chess for real
tournaments when I was 10 years old and
one covet hit and from there we were at
the Mechanics Institute earlier and you
were there as well you got a chance to
hang out with Prague Anish and Wesley
how was that for you uh it was great you
know getting to know them and seeing
them in real life not just online
and getting to another personality
meeting them showing off and telling
stories I guess did you have a fun chat
with them yeah I showed them my board uh
oh my autographs and they were very
intrigued by it so cool and you're here
today are you looking forward to meeting
Magnus uh yeah she's the one that I've
left out of all four uh I'm very excited
especially because he is the King of
Chess uh good at glitch bullet rapid
Glasgow
now remember back at The Institute you
mentioned that you're rooting for Wesley
you must be happy to see that he's won
all his four matches
I'm very happy that he had a great
comeback especially I think this cost
was from the global Chase Championship
even though he lost the first two games
he can't came back and is doing better I
have to ask you who is there are so many
great players here in the US who is your
personal favorite
my favorite chess player in the US
probably Hikaru Nakamura because I love
playing Blitz and he's like the Blitz
the best Blitz player and I also like
Wesley so his personality and his
kindness yeah he's super kind but do you
think Hikaru is the strongest when it
comes to speed chess
uh yes I feel like he's probably gonna
win the speed Chess Championship coming
up tomorrow I'm pretty sure and yeah I
wish him good luck wow and akaya there
is a little story here with sub and
Hikaru this was at the candidates tell
us about this it's a nice score sheet so
this was I was playing in the chess kid
candidates during the candidates that
happened in the morning so we finished
in the morning and after I finished in
the morning the feet ahead Arbiter of
the tournament Anastasia
she went and gave me the score sheet of
Hikaru ding Lyon the first game
um I I was so happy and I went down
since the current ding finished and I
got them both to sign the autographs on
each
and I think this is hikaru's handwriting
I'm not sure though
wow so the top chess players continue to
inspire the young Generations lots of
moves happening lots of inspiring moves
happening on the chessboard right now
back to you guys in the studio oh thank
you Sebastian and Tanya how how cool is
that score sheet that could actually be
the next World Champion signing that
dingley Wren who will pay on the
pobnachi next year for the world
championship title
very cool very cool do you guys keep
your score sheets I keep all of them I
don't think I've ever been to squishy
and I know your bank is different though
Ivanka doesn't keep them and if Ivanka
loses she rips them up
because it's like all that that bad
karma gone and uh yeah but uh I do kind
of do keep memorabilia I do like to keep
little tokens and you take the pieces
and stuff
not advocating
just bringing the whole board I'll take
this home as a memory
that's just theft yeah
and then we see the king escape from the
king side and move towards the center
and whilst the players are thinking I do
want to share with you one very nice
tweet from claritza who tells us the
bigger the pout the better the game and
he's done a drawing of our favorite gold
medalist commentator and she's got your
autograph there as well David shout out
to Marissa yeah I think we met briefly
in Chennai Marissa was playing as well
in the Olympiad and yeah I'm honored
thank you
uh yeah I think that picture was based
on one of the games that I played there
as well I can see with the England
jacket that's right yeah the England
Blazer that we're very proud of
am I wearing the same shirt here that I
was there that's embarrassing I don't
think the pink one yeah oh that's very
cool thank you Maritza a talented artist
drawing a talented chess player it's
very nice yeah and uh in the meantime
the pawns have moved up the board but
I'm fully expecting the white Rook just
to move two squares to get behind
Black's past sea porn and oh he gives a
check first yeah that shows that Magnus
is playing for the win he really
shouldn't get too carried away he should
try and play the safe uh over the next
few moves because Black's rook and
Bishop do actually combine better than
White's record Knight but uh yeah it
should still be within the drawing
margins here white did have the
opportunity to force the drawers you
mentioned Ivanka if you go for Black Sea
Pawn in time yes you lose your a pawn as
white but those two pawns on the left
side will disappear it's completely
symmetrical on the other flank dead draw
but suddenly where's White's night going
is Magnus Really Gonna Get greedy and
try and grab some of those black porns
on the right side because then you're
forgetting about the Black Sea Pawn
and look at this suddenly a check
White's night is getting kicked away
the black porn might be motoring forward
it's Magnus on tilt he's got 10 minutes
he hasn't used any time at all uh he's
just
feels to me as if he's already risking
significantly here he needs to pull that
handbrake and say okay let's find a draw
now
because Black's pieces are just looking
fantastic that's King as well it's
valuable piece in these types of end
games it can Shepherd pawns forward
white tonight retreating I just feel
that Magnus is being complacent he feels
like he can play almost anything he
likes and it will still be a draw but
he's taking such big risks here because
as you say Black's pieces are swarming
forward and you've got to always
remember when it comes to the end game
is the quality of the pawns not the
quantity so in terms of quality it just
depends on like how far Advanced they
are up board whether they can promote
easily and there we see Duda just
attacking the night tonight will have to
move or be defended yep I'm expecting
maybe the king to retreat and defend
this but
yeah where are you going with your
Knights you have to run to some very
awkward squares if you want to find
safety
maybe Magnus was just having one eye on
the clock he sees that dude is down at
one minute and he thought okay I'm gonna
take some calculated risks some measured
risks but one minute for a player like
Duda is still a lot of time
so it is time to backtrack to backpedal
and try to stay safe I advocate just
defending that night now with the white
king
think it's still okay because White's
Pawn White's A6 Pawn will cause a
distraction at some point where it's
Rook will be able to slow behind
attacking that black C Pawn maybe giving
some checks later
so there's enough defensive resources
but suddenly the tightrope
is narrowing of a very small path to
hold the draw with white okay I reckon
that Magnus will not defend that night
yeah I think he'll move it I no I think
he's going to move his Rook to the
eighth row okay that would be very
sneaky Ivanka so this position should be
a draw but there's always tricks
involved and Magnus could set a little
trap here just by ignoring the threat on
this Knight this is very pretty just
stepping forward with the white rook and
now if the Knight is captured then white
would win a check and a skewer if the
King has to run out the way next move
the black Rook would drop and white will
make a new Queen so it's never too late
to set traps that would also be very
interesting the reason you plant The
Rook forward one square is because right
now uh yes the Knight is attacked but
you can't come back and check because
Black's Bishop covers that square so you
just threatened to jump to a light
square and uh yeah I guess here just to
illustrate why we think this will be a
draw eventually Black's Pawn at some
point will start to push and maybe white
has better here even but just as an
example the white Rook will slide behind
this Pawn will disappear this Pawn will
disappear and
yeah the king-size structure here on the
right side no way to make head roads
into that one so dead draw okay
there is now 55 minutes left to cast
your vote for the best game of the
Champions chess tour season 2022 only 55
more minutes so the way to do it is you
head to chest24.com tour if you scroll
just a little bit down you will find the
vote there are nine games you can move
for you'll find the link to the chest 24
site where you can check the games
there's also videos for each of the
games Magnus is nominated for a few of
them Duda is also nominated in a few of
them there is that big big mama Dr of uh
game when he beat Anish giri
there are nine different games and you
have now 55 minutes to cast your vote
this is one of the bonus prices this
season so the winner is the two players
in that game will get a big bunch of uh
that uh bonus price fund which is over
80 000 big right now
Magnus nominated for quite a few of them
actually I think there's two Carlson
Duda games that you can vote for wow
yeah I mean these two they've had some
real ding dong battles throughout the
year and okay with this last move Magnus
didn't go for the draw we saw the white
king poke its head out black checked the
king back and the position repeat itself
once Magnus is playing on he's attacking
this black Bishop but I'm wondering what
happens here if for example black tries
to keep things simple and just takes the
White Knight does white have anything
better than taking the black Bishop then
we would see a draw most likely
still Ivanka yeah I mean I would
actually be tempted to try to play for
more you know Magnus is taking risks why
can't black do the same I would be
tempted just to retreat the bishop one
square forward
C5 yeah back to C5 and kind of again
asked the question or I could uh if I
was feeling super confident actually I
might even put the bishop on the D2
Square because after all the bishop on
D2 will got the ace sorry c one square
that's really ambitious and dude is
ticking down to 30 seconds
if he moves his Bishop we will see a lot
of twists and turns ahead I think if he
wants to play it safe if he wants to
commit to the draw now Duda he'll just
take the White Knight with blacks Rook
but he's not got that much time he looks
away maybe in a bit of frustration there
Duda but uh now we will see the game
steer towards the draw the bishop
disappears Black's Rook has got to go
after that white a pawn before it's too
late
put it back where it came from that Rook
and the game is automatically almost a
draw there's no way to keep these two
pawns on the board
and uh before the game quickly Fizzles
out we do have a caption this
competition where you can answer using
the hashtag chess Champs and there The
Rook does go behind the pawn the game is
gonna fizzle out and any second now
they'll find a way to repeat the moves
okay there we go check the king and Rook
do a little dance the position repeats
itself and it has been a hardcore game
but it is a draw
first game in their match a draw Magnus
Carlsen taking a big sip of the liquid
death the nice water sparkling water
that they are drinking in Shack 15